nice steal by butler  got it in front of warren and all the  way in to finish  you can't have a one-on-one when you go  back to jimmy butler anticipation  brogden basically telegraphed that pass  and  i can tell where that time was going  that's like talking  who do you think he was referencing i'm  just saying  it could have been somebody else i don't  know do they have a history i'm confused  that's why i'm asking you you're the pro  i'm asking you  it's interesting tj warren a lot of  people with the pacers say  he loves the bubble he's introverted he  likes to practice  he's a very quiet guy and yet butler has  made him animated  and so we're following this and the  coaches of obliged by having them guard  each other well i like the intrigue  i love to have individual battles but  the thing about it they don't take away  from what they need to do  for their team okay they still they  still play team basketball which is most  important